Okay. Uh my my second question is it's
on social justice if you wouldn't mind.
Uh oh. What about it? You want to be
just socially?
Uh what's the question? In the movement.
Uh yeah, in the room in the US. So I was
dealt with the sort of this this dilemma
I was thinking about in terms of to what
degree of charity can a Christian um
give. So my question is this. If there
is such a case where other houses of
worship or other temples of demol houses
of worship are demolished, is it
biblical for a Christian to advocate for
the rebuilding of other houses of
worship to be generous in that sense or
absolutely not. What would you
Absolutely not. No Christian gives any
single penny to build houses of Satan
where false gods,
goddesses, and snare people to demons
because Paul says behind every idol is a
demon. So to say, I'm going to help a
Hindu build a Hindu temple where he's
going to be worshiping Satan and various
demons. unbeknownst to him. That means
I'm complicit in the sin and helping
that person speed up his destruction in
hell. That is wicked. Do unto others as
you'd have them do unto yourself. Love
your neighbor as yourself. And if I know
this is a demon or Satan that they're
worshiping to their
destruction, then I'll do everything I
can to stop them from being ins snared
by the devil. Because if I'm ins snared
by the devil and you know I am and you
don't help me to escape a snare, then my
blood will be on your hands.
Wow. Of course. Read 1 Corinthians 10 19
and 22 and pay attention to verse 20. 1
Corinthians 10 19-22. If Paul forbids
Christians, If Paul forbids Christians
from eating sacrifices to idols because
they're demons behind the idols, you
think Paul said, "But it's okay. Helps
finance their temples for the glory of
Jesus Christ to show them love."
Right. Right.
It's like saying, "Let's support Planned
Parenthood who justifies the of unborn
children so we can show support for
these women who are pro-choice so they
can see that Jesus is in us because we
we love them enough to help them child."
Come on, man. But anyway, read 1
Corinthians 10 19-22.
[Music]
2020.
Okay. Okay. So, this is first Corinth.
Oh, hold
on. Firstians 10. 1 Corinthians is after
Genesis. 1 Corinthians 10:19-22.
Oh, I don't know the 10. Yeah. Chapter
10. Little
Okay. What say I then the idol is
anything? All that which is offered and
sacrificed to idols is anything. But I
say that the things which the Gentiles
sacrifice, they sacrifice to devils and
not to God. What do they sacrifice to?
Who do they sacrifice to? They
sacrifice to devils.
Not to God,
right? To devils.
Demons. You catching it because you're
not responding. Devils. Demons. Yeah.
So, how are you going to help finance a
place of Satan where Satan demons and
snare people to their destruction?
How you going to do that? Should you
help finance? Let me let me add a
follow-up. Should you help finance
synagogues? Absolutely not. Do you know
why?
Do you know why? Because they bless
Because they not only they blasphe the
Lord Jesus Christ and they don't know
the true God. Jesus said those Jews who
reject them are fake Jews and their
synagogues belong to the devil. Go to
Revelation 3 7-9.
Whoa. Revelation 37-9.
29.
Okay. And to the angel of the church
in
Philadelphia, right? These things say he
that is holy, he that is true, he that
hath the key of David, he that openeth
and no man shutth and shutth and no man
openeth. I know thy works. Behold, I
have set before thee an open door, and
no man can shut it. For thou hast a
little strength, and hast kept my word,
and has not denied my name. Behold, I
will make them of the synagogue of
Satan, which say they are Jews, and are
not, but do lie. Behold, I will make
them to come and worship before thy
feet, and to know that I have loved
thee. The synagogue of Satan. So, their
synagogue belongs to Satan, their
father. these Jews who don't know the
Lord Jesus Christ who reject Jesus
Christ and are fake Jews because a true
Jew will be someone who worships Jesus
Christ. And he says their house of
worship belongs to the devil. It's not a
place where God is worshiped. And this
is referring to the Jews in
Philadelphia. Now go to Revelation 2 and
read 8-9. Revelation 2
8-9. Yeah.
Okay. And onto the angel of the church
in
Simina. These things, right? Sorry.
Sorry. No, you're not sorry. You're
happy. Uh, the church in Smyrna. Read it
again. Revelation 28 tonight. Oh,
Smyrna. Okay. And unto the angel of the
church in Smyrna, right, these things,
saith, the first and the last, which was
dead and is alive. I know thy works and
tribulation and poverty, but thou art
rich. And I know the blasphemy of them
which say they are Jews and are not, but
are of the synagogue of S. Did you catch
it? Here are two different geographical
locations. Smyrna, Philadelphia, the
Jews in Smyrna and the Jews in
Philadelphia who don't believe Jesus
Christ, who go to synagogues. Jesus says
the synagogues in Smyrna, Philadelphia
belong to Satan, their true father. And
though they're physically Jews, they are
fake Jews because they reject the Lord
Jesus. They're not true Jews.
Okay, you get it? Yeah. So if Jesus told
you the synagogues of the Jews who
reject the Lord Jesus Christ belongs to
Satan, are you going to help support and
finance synagogues?
No, of course not. Thank you. There you
go. You got your answer. That was your
second question. Do you have a follow-up
or do you have a third one? Go ahead.
Keep going.